having to tell your kids that they can't
get something because you've no money
it's ridiculous
it's going to be very hard
it's going to be very hard when the
lockdown was imposed the government
increased universal credit payments by
20 pounds a week they always said it was
a temporary measure but its removal has
been fiercely contested
it's unaffordable to plunge working
families into destitution and poverty if
they cut that that's going to be a big
chunk of our food shopping that we're
not going to be able to afford so what
lies behind the decision to end the
universal credit uplift why is it so
controversial and who could be worst
affected
it was a temporary measure recognized
for the extension
that's not an answer i mean saying that
it was a temporary measure you could
carry on with it if it was proved to be
working effectively it has been proved
working effectively are you entirely
happy with this yes
to understand why the removal of the 20
pound weekly increase has become such a
major issue it's important to first
understand how the system actually works
universal credit has two key aims the
first is to streamline welfare by
merging a number of old-style benefits
like income support working tax credits
and housing benefits into one
the second is to prevent an income cliff
edge for someone going from unemployment
into work the conservative architects of
the system wanted to address what they
called the benefits trap and that meant
tackling the idea that someone could be
better off on benefits than in work
universal credit aims to do this by
easing the transition from unemployment
into work by reducing benefits gradually
as employment income increases
[Music]
because the whole point of uc is to
encourage people into work the amount it
pays out is not intended to provide a
comfortable income on its own
the 20 pounds increase introduced during
the pandemic was effectively an
acknowledgment that finding a job or
increasing working hours would be very
difficult in a lockdown
now those restrictions have eased the
government believes it's right to return
to the previous rate
particularly given average wages are
rising and there are record vacancies in
the jobs market the best way we can help
people is to get them into
high-wage employment but critics say
it's not as simple as that charities
opposition parties and campaign groups
insist the welfare state has to provide
a safety net and that the temporary
increase in universal credit showed its
basic rate wasn't sufficient in the
first place
they point to the fact nearly 40 percent
of those claiming the benefit are
already in work but many of them are
still struggling to make ends meet the
20 pound uplift going i really really
can't sleep overnight and that is the
truth i just lay there worrying so much
we know that people were struggling
already before the pandemic we know from
our research that people were having to
make really difficult decisions about
you know whether they were going to be
able to put food on the table where
they're going to be able to clothe
people clothe their children whether
they were going to be able to
heat their houses
there'll be a question between fuel and
food or clothes and food you know it's
something which will make a massive
massive impact the pandemic has seen a
huge increase in the number of people
applying for universal credits at the
end of august the number stood at almost
6 million claimants the 20 pound cut
amounts to
1040 pounds a year according to the
joseph rowntree foundation working
families will make up the majority of
those affected
research by action for children has
found that hairdressers pharmacy
assistants and shelf stackers will see
the biggest overall drop in their
benefits and the trussell trust
estimates that nearly a quarter of a
million parents on universal credit are
worried about not being able to put
dinner on the table for their children
when the uplift is removed
it's a big deal for us it does help us
through along the way honestly
it does help a lot so without 20 pound
taking off i think a lot of family are
going to be struggling
but the significant number of people
claiming uc is one of the reasons that
the government believes maintaining the
20 pound uplift is not sustainable
they say maintaining it would cost
around 6 billion pounds a year and as a
permanent spending commitment that would
have to be paid for with an increase in
income tax for everybody else at at
least a penny in the pound
it was always meant to be a temporary
measure along with lots of other things
that we've done those things can't carry
on
boris johnson does not have unanimous
support for this policy from his party
ranks the cut is opposed by six former
conservative work and pension
secretaries it's thought enough
conservative mps opposed the decision
that it could have tested the
government's majority if it had ever
been put to a binding vote in parliament
but that didn't happen and now those mps
nervously await the consequences
according to sky's election analyst
michael thrasher there are 28 marginal
constituencies recently gained by the
tories which have a high number of
people claiming universal credit if
there is a big political blowback on
this issue at the next election that
could be a problem for the party
you're playing with people's lives and
people don't forget
and as boris said you know he's
he's borrowed our votes from the north
yeah and borrowing means you can take
them away as well the chancellor hopes a
new 500 million pound household support
fund will lessen the impact of reducing
universal credit
the question is whether that will be
enough given that the end of the uplift
is coming as energy and fuel prices are
soaring living costs are up and a
national insurance hike is coming down
the track